[Music]
Sugar Hill Creamery is problems only
family-owned tonight from Shockley open
the July 29 2017
my name is Sherman lacasa I am the
founder and CEO of elimination brand
limeade my name is Miguel Martinez and
we
[Music]
shaving products specifically gear
people with textured hair this is our
Harlem buyer fare it is an opportunity
for the vendors that we've been working
with for about a year to showcase their
product and showcase their business
to buyers both from Columbia University
and Whole Foods Market as well as other
corporate buyers throughout New York
City and throughout the nation
Harlan Proctor Park is a social
enterprise that represents about 200
businesses in Harlem many of which are
the retail restaurants service
businesses but a growing population
within our organization is local
suppliers of parlormaid products the
vendors that are here today have all
been working for the last five or six
months to prepare to be able to pitch to
about a hundred and fifty buyers and
procurement representatives that are
here from retail corporate retail as
well as institutions that are looking to
buy products that are made locally Whole
Foods is all over the city now and we
have 12 stores in New York City but you
know we really like each sort of a
unique experience for the shoppers so
Harlem shoppers would get a different
experience than Brooklyn shoppers would
get a different experience than Midtown
shoppers and that's why the brands are
so important based on where they're made
and which stores we place them in so
it's really important to us it's really
important to our shoppers it's just
great I think people really like
supporting the brands that are in their
neighborhoods but the Harlem local
vendor program we have been able to get
in in face to face with people like
Whole Foods
you know you can send a package anywhere
and you get turned down but you don't
really know why you're turned down being
part of a look above the program you're
allowed to get a lot of feedback for
your brand and that is part of you know
one of the real reasons why this program
has been invaluable to me as an
entrepreneur I actually work with Harlem
park-to-park in the business school as
an advisor on the committee so I'm
involved in the cohorts who comes in I
actually teach a class from a very
practical purpose on what to do and it's
not just this campus as we look forward
to Manhattanville we're looking at local
folks to also fulfill the leads on that
campus
- Nick and I are partners in life and in
work and shop was a part of the Harlem
park-to-park Columbia whole food
collaboration basically a condensed
business school that Nick participated
in
their teachers taught me a lot about you
know things I didn't know about
marketing things I didn't know about
finance that kind of fine-tuned my
business plan then adapt and make
changes to to our business before we
opened and it's a great opportunity to
to network with the university and other
businesses in Harlem so this is
something that you know it's beneficial
to the community and we're basically
becoming this kind of of a broadly based
community-based consultant that's
helping entrepreneurs and other
businesses grow in the community of
Harlem I went from being the guy you
know with good formulations not very
good branding to a CEO and a guy that's
now grown his brand to where it's now in
major retail and without Columbia's
influence and their help and their
disassociation it wouldn't have happened
even events like today where you know
all of my all of my large retail
relationships are as a result of my
affiliation with Columbia SBDC Columbia
University has three campuses in Upper
Manhattan and it's very important for us
to support the community both in terms
of the businesses as well as the
residents who live here and this is just
one of many opportunities that
we're that we're happy to offer